how many Sprints are there in the week
how do you break that down so we do four
Sprints a day four Sprints a day yeah so
two phone Sprints two digital Sprints so
if you do four Sprints then so what does
that look like in the day yeah so we
basically we start at half eight we do a
standup we talk about what our
non-negotiables are and and what we're
planning to do for the day 9:00 to 11:00
is our first business development Sprint
11 to 1 is then our follow-up Sprint to
that because typically when you've done
a phone Sprint you've got lots of
actions off the back of it that you need
to follow up on yeah then we have lunch
kind of do a bit of prep work work we do
a little stand up again and sort of get
together before our candate Sprint talk
about what we're looking to achieve so
two to four is our candate Sprint and
then four till six we'll do our digital
Sprint and that will include any kind of
admin booking interviews interview
feedback that kind of stuff